take a look at this picture
this is james bond he's the typical
archetype of the hero
he's perfect he's smooth strong
assertive
handsome never makes mistakes and idol
he is the quintessential man so to speak
now look at this picture
this is charles bukowski he's the
typical archetype of the anti-hero
he was rebellious he was mediocre he was
ugly
he was a rascal but he possessed an
extraordinary skill
he was an exceptional writer at least
for some people
myself included bukowski was born in an
age when
the idea of the american dream was at
its zenith
everyone wanted to have the perfect job
the perfect house
the perfect wife the perfect husband
some did achieve it
some didn't the ones who did realize
soon enough
that the american dream was a fad a
story invented by marketers to sell a
healthy version of capitalism
that could maintain the idea of
consumerism and keep the machine running
the moment they got what they so
immensely desired
reality hit them hard and they
understood that the american dream
wasn't as lucrative as it seemed
the ones who didn't were just looking at
the ones who did
with jealousy and with an astute lack of
awareness
of what was happening behind the scenes
bukowski belonged to the second category
his parents were german immigrants and
he was raised in a poor and abusive
environment
growing up his chances of success and
the potential pursuit of the american
dream
were minuscule he found himself working
menial jobs
while trying to make ends meet until he
eventually settled a job in a post
office
writing was for him an escape and a way
to relieve his mental pain
pain transformed into depression and
this depression bolstered his rage as he
grew older
and gave him much of his voice and
material for his writings
bukowski didn't receive any praise for
his great ability to present
reality in such a raw and poetic way
until his early 50s
when his writings became known though he
amassed a following so devoted and
ecstatic with his work
that even the most vigorous proponents
of the american dream would envy
bukowski wasn't by any means the perfect
person
even during his most successful days he
didn't feel that his life was perfect
life was for him a perennial absurdity
that
included instances of perfection like
women
booze writing and public orations for
his fans though he was an idol
he represented ideas that deeply
resonated with their soul
and allowed them to picture reality
through an unconventional
and anti-heroic lens for them this was a
big deal
for them he was perfect
human nature can be summarized as the
eternal effort
to transcend the limits of our abilities
in an attempt to escape
everything wrong with a human condition
since the dawn of the human
consciousness and the
realization of the fact that we are
aware of our own existence
we have been trying to create stories
that allow us to make this existence
more
meaningful the idea that there is no
meaning and that
we just are was quite unappetizing so
the people who were able to create the
most
beguiling and convincing stories were
the ones whose stories
dominated the world these stories
usually included various inaccuracies
and metaphysical
explanations of obscure phenomena but
their theme was very similar
there is a divine or heroic entity that
created the world as we can experience
it and
this entity is regarded as the
manifestation of the ideal human
he is omnipresent omniscient and
omnipotent
in simple words he is perfect the moment
we believe in stories about divine and
heroic entities that
represent the ideal version of us and in
a way
what all of us ought to become we fall
prey to the influences associated with
the path to reaching that state the
consequences of such a situation are
innumerable
living a life while holding the
conviction that whatever you do should
aim for perfection is stressful and
non-nervous to say the least
especially if you don't really know
whether you will ever reach that perfect
state
especially if you never really know if
your attempts will ever be appreciated
let's just face it we're all victims of
perfectionism
when i decided to start this channel i
was deeply convinced that we should all
strive to become
the quintessential versions of ourselves
so to speak
back then i couldn't grasp the
ramifications that such an endeavor
would entail
when you enter the self-development
sphere you do so in a very enthusiastic
and often times
irresponsible fashion you get star
struck by the luscious titles and the
superficial realities
and you forget to take a step back look
at the bigger picture
and properly evaluate what is good for
you what is interesting
what is actionable what is snake oil and
what is plain nonsense
the virus of perfectionism digs its way
through your core
and instead of becoming the vessel that
will propel you towards
divinity it evolves into an ill-informed
version of a religion
today i see perfectionism the way it is
described by
various self-development outlets as
superficiality
they present a version of reality so
distant and so cheesy that
essentially degrades the true essence of
growth because a person who gets coaxed
into the craze of perfectionism
will suffer the inevitable consequences
associated with the lack of attaining it
consequences like fear of missing out
self-blame
lack of motivation and detachment from
reality to name by the few
if anything i feel that re-engineering
the idea of perfectionism
constitutes a thorny challenge that one
has to construe with caution
nonetheless i will attempt to propose
some ideas that
can act as a starting point for
assuaging the pain
associated with perfectionism and its
byproducts
freud in his monumental work
civilization and its discontents
attempts to identify the most effective
techniques for
alleviating human suffering one of them
is sublimation
for which he states the following
another technique for avoiding suffering
makes us use the displacements of the
libido
that are permitted by our physical
apparatus and lend its functioning so
much flexibility
here the task is to displace the aims of
the drives
in such a way that they cannot be
frustrated by the external world
sublimation of the drives plays a part
in this we achieve most
if we can sufficiently heighten the
pleasure derived from mental
and intellectual work faith can then do
little to harm us
freud's narrative has always fascinated
me despite the numerous objections his
theories have faced
no one can really question the depth and
thoroughness of his work
civilization and its discontents was one
of his last works and therein we can
discover a holistic interpretation of
his ideas
sublimation is a psychological term used
to denote the process of
deflecting sexual instincts into acts of
higher social evaluation
for example instead of constantly
chasing new partners
one can focus more on things like arts
reading writing
or activism in his view all of human
motivation originates from the libido
libido creates sexual impulses and to a
large extent
the need for power most people are
unable to satisfy these needs
and they eventually become neurotic and
even aggressive
the principle of sublimation can
influence the functioning of our mental
apparatus
in such a way that it can allow it to
focus on higher pursuits
in an attempt to stay psychologically
balanced
such a shift of consciousness can have a
tremendous impact on the way we view the
world
but also on the way we view ideas like
perfectionism
although at the beginning of the video i
stated that idols could create false
equivalences of perfection
the strategic adoption of archetypes has
always been essential to the development
of the self
because they act as anchors i really
admire jordan peterson and sam harris
for instance
and i consider them my idols i don't
necessarily have to agree with all of dr
peterson's
posits but there is a point to be made
as far as the role of idols and
archetypes is concerned
by understanding the archetypal
structures in your own psychology
and in our culture you understand how to
be autonomous
you must have some values and understand
where these values come from
they don't emerge organically within you
you grow up around your parents and
peers
and copy them and develop some
independence that is empowered by people
you admire
who also got their values from other
people it is a synergistic process
where do those values come from and what
exactly are they
that's where archetypes come into play
archetypes according to carl jung
can aid the integration of the ego with
a personal and collective self
they act like a mental compass that can
point the person in the right direction
especially during dark moments however
the role should be confined to this
realm
and shouldn't overwhelm the individual
with the stress of perfection
jordan peterson for example might be an
idol for me
but comparing myself to his perfect
persona so to speak
is inefficacious so use idols and
archetypes strategically
but avoid the mistake of worshiping an
obsession
at the end of the day we're all humans
and you never really know what happens
behind closed doors
a few years ago i started practicing a
martial art from israel
called krav maga i haven't practiced
martial arts for a long time
and my gym offered free krav maga
lessons every monday and wednesday so i
thought i should give it a try
like every novel activity that requires
a lot of patience and practice in the
beginning
it overwhelmed me with nervousness and
sometimes even boredom
i deemed the theory and the repetition
of basic moves quite monotonous and
i found myself questioning the
instructor and even my decision for
joining the course
all that basically because i knew that i
wouldn't be perfect at krav maga soon
and
that annoyed me deeply when i managed to
see beyond my frustration
and allow myself to surrender to the
presence of the practice
the truth really began to crystallize
you don't need to be perfect to enjoy an
activity
you just need to be competent and if you
allow yourself some time for
intensive immersion during the initial
period
you will most certainly become competent
and enjoy it more
epictetus is one of the three main
pillars of the stoic movement
along with marcus aurelius and seneca in
his most famous work the
and heridion he begins with the
following passage
there are things which are within our
power and there are things which are
beyond our power
within our power our opinion aim desire
aversion and in one word
whatever affairs are our own beyond our
power our body
property reputation office and in one
word whatever are not properly our own
affairs
i'm not familiar with as to why he
believes that body
property reputation and office are
beyond our power
but it has probably to do with the
status quo of the time
the essence however remains the same
focusing on our own affairs and things
that are within our power
makes life easier perfectionism is not
within our control
and that's because the notion of what
constitutes perfection
is predicated upon a significant number
of individual opinions
as i stated earlier bukowski wasn't
perfect but he was perfect for his fans
many people considered him repulsive and
a slob does that matter
me for example i have received so many
different comments from my videos
most of them are positive but some of
them are negative
does it matter if i'm able to properly
evaluate my strengths and also monitor
the progress i have made throughout all
these years
why would i focus on ill-informed
opinions
the reason we struggle with insecurity
is because we compare our behind the
scenes with everybody else's
highlight reel the stoics understood
that better than anyone
and that is why their teachings strike a
chord therefore
the stoic philosophy will always be the
best cure whenever one has to deal with
the perfectionism conundrum
there is usually a thin line that
separates reality from delusion
this line is very similar to the one
that separates perfection from
imperfection
the sheer ambiguity involved in the way
we face certain terms
is of utmost importance when trying to
make sense of the world
at the end of the day what matters the
most is self-honesty
and the fact that we should respect our
endeavors
as much as we should respect ourselves
hey guys so this video is sponsored by
skillshare skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
inspiring classes for
creative and curious people and i think
it's a sponsorship that connects well
with the topic of perfectionism
i mentioned in the video that immersion
is what makes an activity actually
interesting
and since i'm working from home most of
the time
i'm trying in my spare time to invest in
different skills that can help me enjoy
the feeling of immersion
and skillshare is a platform that has
helped me
tremendously in that respect for
instance i used to think that i'm really
bad at drawing
but after trying out a couple of drawing
classes on skillshare
i realized that with the right guidance
and practice i can become a great artist
if i really want to
or i had trouble playing the piano by
ear i couldn't play piano without
reading notes and this course actually
helped me realize some piano secrets
that
only professionals and really advanced
musicians can reveal
skillshare is curated specifically for
learning meaning that
there are no ads and they're always
launching new premium classes so you can
stay focused and
follow wherever your creativity takes
you and it's less than ten dollars a
month with an annual subscription
so the first 1000 of you to click the
link in the description below will get a
free trial of skillshare premium so you
can explore your creativity
again thanks for watching see you soon
adrian out
you